they opened fire at Bank branches
others managed to get inside
some were armed
Lebanon has seen a wave of hold UPS in
recent weeks by depositors angry and
desperate to get their savings
informal Capital controls have been
imposed by Banks since the economy began
to collapse three years ago
they're demanding their rights they have
to give it to them reds should not be
wasted people are oppressed isn't it
enough it is enough
depositors unions have declared war
against the banks they're promising to
continue to support people in their
attempts to forcibly retrieve their
savings
and financial meltdown has stripped the
local currency of its value and caused
inflation
the banking Association says the state
and the Central Bank should be blamed
for the crisis since Banks lent money to
the state which hasn't returned it but
many see it differently especially
because of the close connection between
the political and business Elite
including the banking sector
banks are responsible to get our money
back let them sell their assets the
properties they have let them get the
money from their board of directors
there's anger at the central bank as
well for indirectly endorsing Bank
restrictions through circulars that
devalue deposits when they are withdrawn
the World Bank says lebanon's
authorities operated a giant Ponzi
scheme and misused and misspent people
savings over the past 30 years and
despite the worsening crisis they
haven't come up with a recovery plan or
accept to incur any of the financial
losses
among those demanding their deposits
independent first-time MP Cynthia
zarazir who said she needed money for a
surgery it's a story that is heard time
and time again from an increasingly
desperate population Senate Beirut